people make the mistake of making these
big goals these big sort of New Year's
resolutions and we also know that they
often backfire that you know by January
15th a lot of people have given up on
their New Year's resolutions why is it
that we keep making them and keep
failing because they're so big they're
so distant and they require a million
little steps in between and each of
those steps is an opportunity to fail
and they're very much outcome focused
it's not about how I'm gonna feel you
know tomorrow it's I'm gonna lose this
much weight I'm gonna get this kind of
job I'm gonna become a better public
speaker it's things like that I'm gonna
run a marathon I think a lot of research
is showing us that we do much better
when we focus on incremental change on
little bits of improvement we're not
focused on the outcome so we're not
focused on the grade or did you get the
job or not and you're not focused on the
you know big New Year's resolution
you're just focused on the process in
this next moment that's coming up and
that allows you to grow a little bit
over time to not think of each of these
steps as an opportunity to fail and
eventually you know in aggregate you get
there you may not even realize it until
one day you turn around and say wow this
thing is much easier for me now than it
was a year ago I think Carol Dweck's
work on growth versus fixed mindsets to
me that's the most important work around
this idea of self nudging Carol Dweck's
idea is that when you have kids focus on
school tasks not as opportunities to win
or fail but as you know challenges that
will allow them to stretch and grow
that's a growth mindset they do much
better you build children who are
resilient and you know and strong and
actually enjoy school and end up do
well you you build children who thrive
when kids are focused on each grade as a
failure or you know a win so they're
very outcome focused you're not building
resilient kids because people are gonna
fail you know so if they are setback by
every one of those failures they don't
become resilient what I'm talking about
is really the same kind of thing you
know you you change your body language
you go into that next big challenge and
you feel a little bit calmer a little
bit safer and most importantly you leave
not feeling that sense of regret not
feeling like I didn't show them Who I am
you leave feeling like I show them Who I
am
and I can accept whatever the outcome is
and that is beautiful I mean I would say
when I look at the thousands of emails
but that I've gotten over the years
since the TED talk people tell me about
some big challenge you know job
interview a test they took confronting
someone who they were having trouble
with standing up for themselves at work
and they don't talk about whether or not
they won what they talk about is how
they feel when they left and and I don't
even know that they know they're doing
that but what they're telling me is I
just felt so much better
I felt like myself I felt that I could
be brave I left feeling good and
sometimes they even forget to tell me
what the outcome was which I think is
but I think it's beautiful
because I would much rather have a world
full of people you know feeling that
they're being themselves and able to
accept an outcome even if it's negative
then a world full of people who are
trying to win all the time
the way to a kind of a healthy and happy
life is not to be focused on winning
it's to be focused on having real
meaningful authentic interactions and
knowing that you did what you could and
that you can't control everything the
other person does or or what they think
of you I mean the key is that instead of
managing the impression that we're
making on others we really need to
manage the impression that we're making
on ourselves right so we need to feel
good about ourselves
we need to feel strong we need to
believe in ourselves and that then leads
us to make a much better impression on
other people but if we're trying to
choreograph and orchestrate it you know
move your hand this way when you say
this word nobody likes that it comes
across as inauthentic and you leave
feeling like a phony